でた今日なんですけどもええ
ちょっと
ぷっ
ってなるかもしれないんですけども僕はこの日のためにここ最近頑張ってきたという節
はあるかもしれないともいえないかもしれないけど実はですね2018年の2月から
従業 wc ですワールドチャンピオンカーワールドは world
championship
世界大会の予選が日本で行われておりま
いろんなねあの授業の後任の店で大会が開かれます大会の優勝者人だけがその拳とかで
場所に集められてどこで1位になった人が国内予選パの日本一を決める大会全国大会
たいと言ってるんですけど
その今お店の各お店の1位を決める大会が2月から始まっております
でそれにどこが出てきたわけなんですよてかこの日のために
結構結構頑張りましたで去年ですよ去年僕5はそのお店で優勝して静岡県の代表を
決める a ブロック戦に出てしぞと拳レスト16まではいってまぁ負けたんですけど
もあの正直本堂
めっちゃ曲悔しくて勝ったか負けたかわかんないんですけど
店で負けたんですねあの時道があるんで是非見てください
美人で負けちゃったんですが悔しくて悔しくて悔しくて悔しくてこと時は
今年もまあ同じレベルまでとは言わないんですけど行けるとこまでいきたいなと思って
まして
実はここ最近ですねもう寝ればもう死んである朝までなんかこういう米考えたりして敵
とか考えたりしてったヘビーが実はずっと続いておりました
この2月からの国内4するとために駅を出てきたんですよ戦に出てきた結果1回戦
wii 2回戦 win
3回戦負けました相馬家だけど13+はもらいましたからね出るだけで酸素ございます
からね負けちゃったんですけどもうその結局そのまま優勝しちゃったんでまぁ
ちゃん病に負けたならばなぁ
ok 南棟あったんですけどちょっと悔しいなっていう思いがすごい
ありますいやーとっても悔しいですね悔しいところではあるんですけども無事の軍曹が
はいめっちゃ悔しかったんですけどもあの実は大会がですね
ペット2月3月4月3ヶ月かかってそこでとりあえず1回で優勝すれば凄く権大会
みたい
県大会に出れるんですよなんか知りません歯の市場にアレなんですけども
この分かれて言わせてくださいあのう
頑張ります
そんだけですでね今日大会でで思ったことがあったんですけど
レベルが上がっていますあなたも勝手に始め軍団って言うなんかね
乳業する仲間を集めたんですけどと今日で大家的で32人なんですよ
そのベスト8の中に姉と一緒によく頑張っている仲間が5人入ってましたベスト8中の
5人がもう身内なんで意外とねなんかちゃんとを練習すればかと言うなってきたなって
いう気はしてますねほんとよく我慢
と外れるのみんなておき俺だ
4番の一打で何かそのカードゲームってちょっと馬鹿にされがちなんですよ
何遊戯よりそんな価値になっててうわぁみたいなこと言われるんですけども僕も馬鹿に
されてもいいと思ってます世界大会ですよ日本で by ツアーやってるんじゃなくて
も4回目指しますからね一応
改善で下手であるんですけども強烈にちょっと頑張ってお店の中で3回戦で負けちゃっ
たんですけど
私はちょっと頑張りたいと思いますしだけで動画が遅くなってごめんなさいちょっと今
後真ん中な
いう業でいっぱいでも何が何でもちょっと勝ちたいところあるんでちょっといますが
ラク乳業集中させてください
なんか遊戯王だけやってますみたいなそういう感じないんですけど eu 以外見せ
ませんですけど
以上ちょっと練習ともうちょっと米と混ぜて勝てないんでいろんなことを込めて
ために動画を
お休みすることが増えると思いますがご了承ください
今
俺が一番頑張りたいことを
頑張りたいと思ってるんで
友情ですけどね今日も大会行ったんですけども大会はですね何回でも出れるんで
2月中もまたまた大会があるんだよもうちょっと頑張ってきます次こそがぞ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ